avec un peu de chance comme je connais
cauet
si vous allez faire la promo de son
émission il aura déjà piqué l'interview
que je vais vous faire là alors moi je
suis pas sûr d'aller faire son émission
tout de suite parce que je suis très
débordé mais non seulement je crois
qu'il t'a piqué tes fiches mais la
pythie mailing j'ai appris ça ouais
interview oui mais
[Musique]
arthur je vous demanderai donc de finir
ma phrase tout simplement je m'appelle
arthur en effet mais mais c'est pas mon
vrai prénom à mon vrai prénom c'est
jacques jacques mon vrai prénom c'est
jacques mais quand j'ai démarré à la
radio j'ai pris arthur parce que ça
sonnait mieux parce que jacques leroy de
la radio jacques et les pirates
s'étaient moyens et j'adore mon prénom
ou dans la une des magazines
estelle et jacques le mariage jacques a
dit oui je vais monter sur scène mais
mais c'est pas sûr parce que si la
douleur que j'ai fait dans le vide
continuez à monte monte monte je crois
que je préfère c'est encore la fin du
site non non non c'est lyon me l'enlever
j'ai été opéré de l'appendicite le jour
où j'ai rencontré ma femme tu veux
croire c'est très con ça en met un doigt
dans le cul
premier touché rectal le lendemain de sa
rencontre n'en attends tu as un peu la
vraie histoire
gfr veut la vraie histoire c'est que
j'ai dîné avec estelle c'était notre
premier rendez vous galant mais comment
on pouvait pas être tous les deux selon
étaient chacun accompagnés et un moment
j'ai commencé à regarder des bouffées de
chaleur elle est de venir plus tard il
ému quand même et je me suis évanoui et
je me suis réveillée j'étais dans un
bloc opératoire et ont opéré
d'appendicite
je n'ai rien contre mon physique mais
mais c'est mon physique il doit avoir
quelque chose contre moi cher j'ai dit
beaucoup de conneries mais j'en ai
produite aussi pas mal hein je suis très
bien sûr tu es la femme est né sais pas
ce soir que tu vas me faire dire du mal
de la chaîne sur laquelle je travaille
ils savent que cela tf1 oui oui il ya eu
comme une rumeur
et alors ils l'ont bien après je suis
sûr non parce qu ils savent que je ne
dis jamais de mal de tf1 je n'apprécie
pas trop l'émission de cauet mais alors
je t'ai dit que c'est une autiste ou pas
j'adore franck dubosc mai mais je crois
que je suis pas le seul la télévision
c'est une grande famille mais mais dans
toutes les familles il sera donc le qui
pue
une tante qui piquent et 1 et un cousin
peu attardé quadra patrick le lay 1
vous avez des soucis avec non
franchement enfin pas dire et ait valeur
acheter j'aime bien
j'aime bien les émissions j'ai présenté
mes mai mais a peut-être une ou deux si
c'était à refaire opté je leur fais pas
lesquelles nice people
ah oui je n'étais pas à l'aise dans son
émission pourrait te fais ça parce qu'à
mon avis non tu sais lors c'est moche ce
que tu fais parce que ce que je t'ai pas
dit c'est que j'ai avec tout l'argent
que j'ai plus j'ai décidé de produire
des jeunes artistes au cinéma à droite
le clavier ton pognon bouge pas on en a
des idées de films aguirre
mais attention tu sais qu'avec moi les
six marches laurent tu veux quoi carton
jaune carton
arthur je ne suis peut-être pas le
meilleur animateur du monde mais ça
m'empêche pas de dormir
ouais évidemment david hallyday est
mieux que moi mais
mais d'abord c'est vrai mais ça fait des
progrès en beau gocité la con mais mais
ah oui je sais où j'ai fait beaucoup de
boules sont a connu la la la qu'est ce
que je peux répondre à ça à mes mais
c'est moi que estelle a choisi ouais je
sais la façon élégante de dire je suis
jalouse mais je saurai attendre que le
petit bébé de mixa bébé les 18 ans pour
lui péter sa gueule celui qui est
toujours lové dans les salles ma femme
et je me sens pas marché alors tout ça
c'est pas dans le spectacle non non non
c'était début du spectacle
non non non non non je me suis promis de
ne pas faire de boue du spectacle ah
d'accord
je ne serai jamais daniel ducruet mai
mais c'est pas grave
non j'ai une vraie star chez les gays
c'est vrai mais mais pas que chez eux
chez les phages aussi c'est que je suis
je communauté jettent ricard dans le
marais j'ai une toute petite [ __ ] mais
mais c'est parce que tu es très très
loin c'est parce que tu les vois de très
très loin
j'adore votre émission entière aimé mais
en tant que producteur et j'aurais
changé des petits trucs
ah ouais ouais il aurait misé le
dimanche soir sur france 3 pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux